businesses are like real estate you can
turn around and sell them after you get
in the game but I think of these
businesses I call them gateway drug
businesses once you learn how to do a
deal you'll never see the world the same
again it will change your entire
perspective on everything you will walk
in everywhere and you will realize that
business is full of masochists like you
and me who do this despite it being
awful many times but we love it in some
way but at some point we're going to
want to sell our thing and move on to
the next and so everywhere around you
right now wherever you are somebody
sitting next to you wants to sell their
business and what if you could figure
out how to buy that business put in an
operator in it and then do it again and
again and again and that's the only
difference between you and Warren
Buffett or Blackstone or these big huge
companies